The joe rogan experience.
I don't know if you'd call it a no.
Tropic nootropic.
How do you say it?
Nutropenia Yeah,
new tropics.
It does say on the thing,
you know,
helps focus and I have to agree.
It really does.
You try this new tropic formula that we've come out with.
We're a,
we're finalizing it and they'd just finished the formula that this guy,
Chris Markus,
have you tried any of it?
You've been trying to,
I'm done with my supply.
This,
this shit gives you the most fucked up,
vivid dreams.
However,
I'm going to get you some last night.
Here's my dream.
My,
the House that I grew up in,
Arnold Swartzman Negar lives in it,
but it's not the house I grew up in.
It's some weird house that's on the rocks right in front of water that
apparently is semi-public.
So Arnold Schwarzenegger is living there now and he's like swimming around.
But all these people are staring at him because of his situation.
And because you know it is scandal,
but he doesn't give a fuck.
Not only is he not give a fuck,
but he's in really good shape now in my dream.
And he keeps wanting to pull his balls out and now he's,
he pulled his balls out,
but he puts his little bikini underwear on,
like,
you know,
like a Frenchman who would wear.
And I was like,
and he pulls his ball somehow or another through the back of his underwear and
there where his ass cheeks are and they're giant.
These giant balls that he has hanging outside of his underwear by his asshole
because somehow or another that big,
and you know,
he's an old man,
but he looks spectacular and he moves like with confidence and grace and dives
into the water.
And I'm like,
I gotta get my wife away from this motherfucker.
I'm looking at this old crazy man.
Like he's just gonna fuck every woman within a,
um,
a mile radius.
And it's like,
he has no,
no inhibitions,
no,
no worries about it.
And all these people are watching him and there's a family that's sitting behind
this rock and they're like,
you know,
there's,
they're sitting there watching Arnold moving around swimming.
It keeps taking his pants off.
He keeps taking his bikini bottoms off and like washing.
But
whatever it is,
it's some crazy what,
I don't know what it is.
I mean,
Freud would have a fucking field day with this chair.
Like,
what is this dream supposed to represent?
Well,
am I terrified of Arnold Sports?
And that would loved to have seen your face while dreaming and just like the
little flinches and you're faced with it whether they were a violence or fear,
you have to look at it like this.
I,
they say one way to analyze dreams as you look at every part of a dream is a
projection of some aspect of your life.
So Arnold Schwarzenegger,
isn't that your ed?
Isn't that your lower primal south?
Some kind of like that.
That would be that,
that,
that dry,
that the sex drive,
the like that drive the power drive.
So you're kind of vanity drive,
you know,
looking at he's a bodybuilder that it's like the most vain thing you could
possibly do.
And then the public ocean,
you could say,
well the public ocean,
that's your,
um,
is that your public life is that you're doing the podcast and you kind of have
like have all your shit in front of everyone on the planet.
And so you're seeing like a projection of your ed swimming through or reacting
to,
like you're thinking,
I'm thinking about all sorts of negatives.
Yeah,
we talked about yesterday.
No,
I don't think it's me.
I don't think that represents me.
I see where you're going with that.
But no,
because what this guy represents to me now,
when I found out that he fucked his maid and his shot loads and it was made in
that,
apparently he was doing it for a long time.
What he represents to me is like this almost like unbridled hedonist that
regardless of the stakes of,
you know,
of whatever fucked up thing that he does sexually.
Now he's the governor,
he's a giant movie star,
multimillionaire married to a Kennedy,
basically.
Shriver's.
She's some sort of a Kennedy,
right?
Yeah.
He know into this respectable family,
but yet banging maids,
fucking all sorts of checks all over the planet.
I'm sure he just never pulled it back,
you know?
And that's,
that to me is amazing.
And what's,
there's something about it in,
in my dream,
he was just completely without,
without remorse.
Within my dream.
He was owning it.
In my dream,
he was,
you know,
this is me.
I'm this crazy freak.
I'm out here.
I bay the UC my balls,
you know what I mean?
That was who he was in my dream was smiling and laughing and waving to people
and he didn't give a fuck,
you know,
but in real life,
I mean,
the poor guy fallen apart in real life.
He's a 60 year old man,
kicked out of his house,
you know,
and his family knows,
he,
you know,
he had a child literally two weeks apart from the,
his own child with the maid,
the maid that was there made for 20 fucking years.
Do you think you'll survive all this?
I know you will.
No,
no.
That's a wrap.
You,
you see what you think?
Like if you made a termino fought fire right now,
Don people are done with him.
How could he do this?
Is this is this is what I think.
I mean,
it's possible.
Anything can happen.
I might be just talking out of my ass.
[inaudible]
yeah.